We're on our final stretch of Fashion Month.
We just got to Paris,
where we're gonna be for the next few days before heading back home.
Tonight, we're getting ready for the business of Fashion 500 gala.
Lamb took us about three hours today,
so we got started quite early.
While I was getting my hair done,
lucky started on his skin.
Since I'm so particular about my makeup,
I keep doing it myself. Lately,
I was in a rush to get ready,
so lucky tape my dress
got me into it before warming whimsy up a bottle.
This point, we were late,
so we rushed to the car and made it onto the carpet.
I was so cold and trying not to shiver,
so I was very glad once we made it inside the building,
we did all the pictures, all the press.
A lot of the times that functions like these,
my social anxiety kicks in a little bit.
I can get quite overwhelming,
but it's always nice to see familiar faces.
We obviously went to the room with all the food first
before going to mingle a little bit more.
It's always fun seeing familiar faces and having fun conversations.
But at this point, mom duties were calling me,
lucky and I went to say hi to a bunch of you guys before heading home.